[Music]
hi I'm Sharlene E and here were some
videos I like here's the first one it's
mr. t man I felt pumped after I watched
this video hope you feel pumped too mr.
t learns the cello boy it wasn't easy
but if I can do it you can do it too so
don't quit don't look at him
I'm talking to you oh the next video is
about a puppy who can't get up
I don't know if I like this video it's
pretty sad it's a puppy who can't get up
but sometimes I kind of put you into
like perspective of like how bad life
could be you could be that puppy that
can't get up
she watched that one and then you should
watch the mr. t one lastly a video I
like to watch a lot to see if SNL has
responded is my SNL audition tape the
first Raymond Raymond Everybody Loves
Raymond be right back
this commercial break hey mom why are we
treating like oh I haven't heard back
yet but I watch it a lot and it makes me
laugh this is my second time auditioning
for us now I heard that you guys might
need some help so oh I make it every
every couple years I made one in 2009 I
mean one in 2013 and I'm in win this
year and next I would like to do my
Monica from Trent's ah so dirty in here
it's so dirty what's going on guys
[Music]
I'm Charlene II and I hope you like the
videos if you don't don't come find me
it's called puppy can't get up
[Laughter]